[Musik]
heute
Regierungsbildung in Mainz mit
Fragezeichen
Jubiläumssitzung in Brüssel ohne
Optimismus die Eierpreise bis Ostern
stabil
guten Abend meine Damen und Herren
in Rheinland-Pfalz wird bereits über
eine neue Regierungskoalition gesprochen
die Sozialdemokraten die gestern bei den
Wahlen sechs Sitze gewonnen hatten
[Musik]
Köln in diesen vor österlichen Tagen
interessiert die Hausfrau besonders der
eierpreis rund 50 Millionen Hennen
stehen in der Bundesrepublik für die
Eierproduktion zur Verfügung die
Deutsche Lufthansa hat heute ihren
pendel-dienst zwischen Hamburg und
Frankfurt eröffnet Airbus vielleicht
schon morgen eine Selbstverständlichkeit
für den Reiseverkehr in der
Bundesrepublik